no this is not in the video where I
officially snap and go crazy though it
looks like it should be
outfit of the day hey you serve a drink
t-shirt and a snack city and between
that muta gurus I just realized I hadn't
said anything on this channel for a
little while so I'm saying hello and
this is not the most exciting video of
all time but I kept wanting to say this
on a daily grace video this week and I
kept forgetting because to err is human
and I am full of air uh I wanted to tell
you guys to go check out my brother
Tim's channel Tim will destroy you and
put the link in the bottom thing and
because he is soon gonna be making a
very concerted effort to post more
regularly on that channel he bought
himself a nice camera he's like taking
this seriously as a thing in his life
can you believe that and for you guys to
support him I think would encourage me
even more to make more than one video a
week and to make them more awesome than
they already are I'm under breath from
talking look at this truck drivers
Princess Bride that's why I wanted to
say I hope you guys are having a great
Friday Friday yeah maybe that's why I
made a video so they don't normally have
to make a video on Friday I don't have a
videos on Saturday so I felt some sort
of withdrawal happening but that'll get
filled by shopping I'm going to Sephora
bayi